le conflit de la pêche se durcit des
ports sont maçons bloqué sur
l'atlantique et en méditerranée commerce
extérieur nouveau déficit de 6 milliards
de francs juillet pologne pour la
première fois depuis le début des grèves
edward gierek fabresse à son pays à la
télévision mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
le conflit de la pêche septembre le
mouvement de grève des marins pêcheurs a
maintenant toucher un effet un très
grand nombre de ports il y a deux
conflits distincts celui de la pêche
industrielle celui de la pêche
artisanale le premier est avant tout un
problème d'emploi les armateurs ont
décidé de diminuer le nombre de marins
embarqués sur landreau chalutier le
second conflit qui s'est greffé sur le
premier et qui s'est traduit très vite
faire le blocage des ports et le fait de
la pêche artisanale les marins pêcheurs
et qui sont leur propre patron voudrait
parmi d'autres allégements obtenir du
gazole à un prix plus bas
voyons avec bernard pradines au où l'on
en est tout conflit confondues si je
puis dire dans ce domaine du blocage des
ports tous les ports de la manche
ressemble ce soir à celui ci boulogne
aucun bateau ne peut entrer ou sortir
les marins pêcheurs ont installé leurs
barrages ce qui a provoqué ici et là des
incidents comme cette bagarre à
granville entre plaisanciers et pêcheurs
incident sans conséquence à cherbourg
par exemple on à échanger aussi quelques
projectiles mais il n'y a eu aucun
blessé
fermée encore calais dunkerque pour les
voyageurs le havre est maintenant le
mouvement s'étend la bretagne
concarneau la turballe l'estuaire de la
loire et plus au sud royan la rochelle
oléron et l'île de ré sur la
méditerranée aucun départ des ports du
nord de la corse bastia calvi et l'île
rousse dans le languedoc fermeture de
sept et de port vendres
plusieurs réunions doivent avoir lieu
demain et mercredi n'est pas impossible
que d'autres ports du littoral manioc
naturellement cette situation a pour
conséquence que de très nombreux
touristes français et étrangers se
trouve immobilisé les plus furieux sont
ceux qui ne peuvent pas partir pour
rentrer chez eux
parmi l'ensemble des gens bloqués il ya
une quinzaine de milliers de touristes
britanniques est la presse anglaise
critique la france avec véhémence dans
les ports bloqués les problèmes sont
nombreux entre autres comment se
ravitailler commando j les diplomates
anglais demande très poliment à leurs
collègues français de faire quelque
chose le plus vite possible pour ses
15000 britannique qui quand très
dignement d'ailleurs dans les ports
bloqués à cherbourg par exemple on
compte sept mille touristes en attente
ce qui pose des problèmes d'intendance
où dormir où manger
comment se procurer de l'argent et
d'autres difficultés de vie quotidienne
il faut d'élite quand les municipalités
en cherche d'urgence du lait pour les
enfants ont fait la queue partout
doha les toilettes de téléphone devant
les toilettes dans les cabines de
téléphone
on s'installe dans la tente la marine
nationale distribuer de l'eau chaude
pour le thé bien entendu il reste un
espoir pour les touristes britanniques
les ports de belgique
plusieurs compagnies de cars ferries ont
décidé de détourner leur bateau vers
ostende par exemple mais la capacité de
ces ferries et du port d'ostende n'est
que de quelques centaines de personnes
ou de quelques centaines de voitures et
les anglais petit à petit malgré leur
flegme perdre patience
ceux ci ont pu la chance d'embarquer les
autres vont venir furent ou
plus fou furieux mais ça gâcher leurs
vacances et des échanges souvent des
ouvriers c'est là la seule occasion de
l'année qu'ils peuvent se permettre un
voyage est comme ça ils sont
complètement déçu et très fâché et si je
ne veux pas dire que c'est le
commencement de la guerre ce sens tôt
mais quand même on est furieux
nos pêcheurs aussi ont été sont très
mécontents de ses éléments les pailles
en attendant il faut bien entendu un
accord en principe on est tout à fait
pour un accord mais entre temps il faut
quand même réussir à voir l'autorité
pour cartes et les ports ouverts aux
bateaux il n'y a pas que les problèmes
des personnes il ya aussi des
conséquences économiques
les port étant bloqués la france ne peut
plus continuer à exporter les
marchandises qu'elle transporte
d'habitude par voie maritime
elle ne veut pas non plus recevoir ce
que l'un porte d'habitude par la même
voie un reportage au havre présenté par
jean claude renoult si on les chalutiers
les artisans pêcheurs s'interroge le
blocage du havre peut-il vraiment les
sauver provoquera-t-il au moins
l'ouverture de négociations puisque la
réunion de demain ne les concerne pas
déjà l'ampleur du conflit et frais
certains 48 bateaux détournés 38 qui
attendent dans la rade
le face à face entre les david de la
pêche et les goliath de la mer continue
aujourd'hui
les marins pêcheurs sont restés
inflexibles ils ont refusé l'entrée d'un
porte conteneurs chargés de 5000 tonnes
de bananes malgré les arguments des
armateurs 5000 tonnes de banane c'est
une part c de la récolte des planteurs
sinistrés de martinique et vous savez
que les bananeraies ont été détruits à
la suite du cyclone s'est donc leur
ultime récoltes et leurs ultimes
ressources qui leur seront
disponible une fois que cette banane
aura été commercialisés les bananes
devront attendre comme tous ceux qui
dépendent directement du port quinze
mille personnes et 300 entreprises
beaucoup des 3500 dockers sont déjà en
chômage technique
sans oublier consignataires transitaires
manutentionnaires et courtiers 500
salles pour les professions réellement
maritime mais vous avez dans la
collectivité locale puis rejoint les
transporteurs routiers la sncf le les
les transporteurs de par barge enfin les
déchets les chalands tout le monde c'est
un drame non ce passé ce blocage
elle s'en va tous encore touché au même
degré ah non bien sûr que non
mais si cette situation devait encore se
prolonger alors nous nous sommes déjà
très très touché mais se fait ce sera
catastrophique pascal en eux mêmes le
havre bella se salit morte
les implications considérables nous
pouvons craindre le limage demain ce
matin les professionnels du port ont
réuni un véritable conseil de crise
leur constat est amer comme la lettre
qu'ils ont adressée aux marins pêcheurs
membres des professions formule c'est
donc deux patrons à patron de nous
désirerions avoir une concertation avec
vous pour discuter en commun de l'eau
par le wall street
moi je crois c'est ouais c'est ça ce
sont des patrons mais je n'ai pas il y a
aussi les touristes anglais et irlandais
font la queue devant l'entrée du ferry
beaucoup moins nombreux qu'à cherbourg
ou à dieppe
ils sont aussi plus flegmatique il faut
dire qu offrent les responsables ont
tout fait pour qu'il soit bien accueilli
il y avait des gens que je n'ai jamais
rencontré avant tout des amis à ce
monsieur là qui nous ont accueillis chez
eux
nous avons des vitres est contre toi dès
le petit déjeuner et ne pouvait pas être
plus générales vous ne revenez pas de
vacances en colère s'est lavé la même
chose peut-être en angleterre très
ennuyeux et puis il ya ceux qui malgré
tout encore chante
regardez bien ce catamaran il a déjà
franchi le barrage des chalutiers
il est immédiatement prise en chasse par
les pêcheurs qui sous l'oeil goguenard
des policiers veulent l'obliger à faire
demi tour
les plaisanciers temps alors de semer
leurs poursuivants en se rapprochant de
la plage réplique des marins un
crevettiers tout terrain après quelques
milles
le catamaran devra finalement faire
demi-tour et rentrer au port
cette bataille là les pêcheurs l'ont
gagnée
les négociations doivent reprendre
demain à wavre il y aura réunion de la
commission de conciliation arbitré par
le directeur des affaires maritimes
monsieur le theule ministre des
transports qui était aujourd'hui
l'invité d'antenne 2010 estime que la
situation des marins pêcheurs est très
diversifiée il est prêté à étudier des
problèmes port par port en somme cas par
cas différentes formes d' aides peuvent
être envisagées mais il ne peut pas être
question pour lui de diminuer le prix du
carburant en effet dans la communauté
européenne un litre de gazole coûte en
irlande un franc 41 au danemark un front
33 en allemagne entre enfants 19 ans 31
et en france un franc 13 à peu près
c'est à dire moins que presque partout
ailleurs mais sur lequel je voudrais
indiquer que le gazole pêche est
actuellement totalement détaxés c'est
dire que l'état ne prend sur le gazole
pêche aucune taxe aucune redevance
lorsque vous allez à compétence vous
payez votre gazole de francs 45 le
gazole pêche est vendu aux pêcheurs un
prend 24 et à partir de ce prix nous
accordons une subvention dead
cette subvention est de 10 centimes et
demi le litre et or cela représente 53
millions de francs à l'échelon national
ça nous est d'ailleurs très
vigoureusement reprocher par la
communauté économique européenne qui
voit là un moyen de concurrence déloyale
dont vous vous dites le résultat j'en
arrive c'est qu'actuellement pour
l'armateur de pêche artisanale ou
industrielle
le prix du gazole en france compte tenu
de cette subvention est le moins cher
d'europe
j'ai sous les yeux tous les prix
effectivement payées dans les pays de la
communauté européenne
c'est en france qu'il est le moins cher
avec des nuances en italie qu'un le
problème en italie se pose différemment
mais je veux dire que sur ce chapitre il
n'est pas possible à l'état d'intervenir
nous avons une politique communautaire
une jeune mis en cause par la communauté
vous savez que nous dénoncions
l'attitude anglaise en certains domaines
parce qu'il y avait les mesures
unilatérales
nous ne pouvons pas en prendre eh bien
monsieur crépeau président des radicaux
de gauche a demandé à monsieur bart la
convocation du parlement en session
extraordinaire consacre confus de là
mais ce retard à dix en charente
l'heure est venue d'un grenelle de la
pêche les milieux politiques de la
majorité commencent à réagir également
un député de paris ce gilbert gantier
bien de poser une question écrite au
premier ministre il s'étonne que le
gouvernement qui est garante des
libertés respecte le droit de grève mais
ne prend pas les mesures nécessaires au
respect de la liberté du commerce dans
les problèmes donc de la pêche
industrielle difficultés de la pêche
artisanale
ce double conflit qui aboutit en
quelques jours à la situation que nous
venons de vous montrer n'est pas la
manifestation brusque d'une crise
passagère c'est l'illustration d'une
situation d'ensemble de la pêche
française situation qui a commencé à se
détériorer en 1975 c'est à dire au
moment de l'aggravation de la crise de
l'énergie jean-marc hills oui la
situation des pêcheries française et
européenne n'a cessé de se dégrader
depuis cinq ans parce que désormais ou
pêche moins et surtout plus cher
- parce que certaines espèces comme le
hareng sont en voie d'épuisement et
doivent être protégés - aussi parce que
l'accès aux zones de pêche est désormais
limité par la souveraineté des pays
riverains comme la grande-bretagne
traité de bruxelles ou pas plus cher
parce qu'il faut un litre de fioul pour
ramener un kilo de poisson et que le
prix du fioul a augmenté de 600 % depuis
73 des recettes qui stagne des coûts
l'exploitation qui s'envole personne
n'est épargné ni les armateurs de
boulogne ni les artisans d'où le double
conflit
les marins de boulogne n'accepte pas une
réduction de leurs effectifs à leur
refus viennent s'ajouter les
revendications des artisans qui
réclament eux une nouvelle ados
carburant le gouvernement dit non
bruxelles dit il ne tolérera pas une
nouvelle entorse à la concurrence
bien sûr 30 millions de francs ont été
dégagés pour le maintien de la flotte
mais l'aide du gouvernement ne pourra
bénéficier qu'à ceux des armateurs qui
aurait déjà rééquilibrer leurs comptes
avec des équipages moins nombreux ce que
refusent les syndicats ou bien après une
réorganisation de la commercialisation
que les artisans eux affirment ne
pouvoir attendre
la france qui produit 700 mille tonnes
de poissons parents dépensent chaque
année 3 milliards de francs pour ses
importations essentiellement en
provenance de la communauté et le
secteur des pêches maritimes emploi
25000 naviguant en france au début du
mois d'où un rapport du 8e plan rappelé
l'urgence des mesures de restructuration
des pêcheries française et la nécessité
d'un règlement européen
mais la crise d'aujourd'hui pourra
difficilement attendre le règlement
toujours retardée d interminables
querelles européennes
en pologne la situation est plus en plus
graves en arrive à une crise politique
sans précédent dans une démocratie
populaire
le nombre de grévistes notamment dans
les chantiers d'epr de la baltique s'est
à nouveau accrue un comité de grève
interentreprises compte aujourd'hui des
représentants d'une soixantaine de celle
ci et le comité demande aux pouvoirs
publics beaucoup de choses notamment le
droit de faire grève inconnue jusqu'ici
un pays socialiste la liberté de parole
la suppression de la censure la
libération de détenus politiques et
serra tandis que le bureau politique du
comité central du parti ouvrier polonais
se réunit le numéro un
même si guirec a décidé d'ajourner le
voyage qu'il devait faire en allemagne
fédérale et intervenante en public pour
la première fois depuis le début du
conflit il devait prendre la parole à la
télévision un extrait de ce qu'il a dit
traduit par notre confrère jean offredo
mes chers citoyens et compatriote les
événements de cette dernière semaine et
même de ces derniers jours nous cause
une inquiétude profonde
les arrêts de travail dans plusieurs
régions du pays
trouble la vie normale et désorganise le
pays c'est exactement la situation
quelles sont les principaux foyers du
mouvement qu'elles sont en dehors des
chantiers navals les secteurs touchés
nous aimerions pouvoir vous montrer des
images mais d'une part nous ne recevons
pas de pologne à ce propos et d'autre
part les télévisions occidentales ne
peuvent pas tournée elle même des
reportages sur les événements de
varsovie par téléphone le représentant
permanent de la fp jean-michel tondre un
coup de téléphone donné cet après midi
le mouvement de grève des ouvriers
polonais ne cessait de gagner en ampleur
à quelques heures du discours de
monsieur gerets dans la conurbation de
gdansk sopot et gdynia 88 établissements
industriels sur environ 1 100 avait
rejoint le comité de grève intérêts
entreprises
l'ensemble du secteur de la construction
navale était paralysée arrêt de travail
également dans la même région un album
et elle est blonde réseau l'ouest à
szczecin entre grand port polonais de la
baltique et plus
tout à l'heure un absolu une
intervention de la milice a interrompu
une réunion du cor le principal
mouvement dissident en pologne un des
participants a été interpellé l'accusé
cendres à votre avis monsieur guirec
continue à parler à la télévision
polonaise voici à nouveau une traduction
par jean fred on est bien le monsieur
edward gierek a d'abord fait une sorte
d'auto critique de la politique du
pouvoir polonais disant que en dehors de
faits objectifs que l'on pouvait voir
il est évident que la crise
d'aujourd'hui se fonder sur une crise
économique profonde et qu'en particulier
depuis dix ans il y avait des choix qui
avait été fait et qui devait être remis
en question et monsieur des règles de
dire nous devons remédier à tout cela
dont seulement sur le plan des
investissements sur le plan de
l'agriculture sur le plan du commerce
extérieur mais aussi cela devrait
entraîner des changements de personnel
et approcher comité central doit y être
consacrés après cette autocritique
il a ajouté nous comprenons je comprends
les difficultés de la vie quotidienne en
particulier c'est que que nous voyons
partout mais at il ajouté les grèves que
nous voyons se développer actuellement
n'apporte rien et ne peuvent résoudre
des difficultés et ensuite de dire en
leur en quatre points comme quoi faire
premièrement le bureau politique est en
régnier réunis en permanence doit
analyser les changements qui sont
nécessaires
deuxièmement il ya eu depuis le début
juillet des augmentations de salaires il
y en aura d'autres troisièmement il y
aura une décision du gouvernement qui
est vrai maintenant non seulement
d'arrêter l'augmentation du prix de la
viande jusqu'à l'automne 80 mais aussi
de bloquer les prix des produits de
grande consommation et enfin une
augmentation des allocations familiales
voilà en gros si vous voulez après le
guéry continue de parler et appelle à la
responsabilité et à la compréhension de
tous
la situation économique de la pologne
avec des mains difficile aussi bien sur
le plan de l'économie nationale qu'en ce
qui concerne l'existence quotidienne
un bilan par jean pierre vion
l'accroissement de 10% des salaires
revendiquée par les ouvriers polonais
n'a a priori rien d'exagéré
le salaire moyen est en effet
actuellement en pologne de 5300 flottis
par mois environ 760 francs
mais en fait le pays est aujourd'hui
dans un véritable cul-de-sac économique
avec l'équivalent de 80 milliards de
francs de dettes
il est l'un des premiers débiteur de
l'occident encore y at il là qu'un
problème parmi d'autres il faut y
ajouter une forte inflation engendrés
par la spirale des prises et des
salaires
un marché chroniquement perturber un
ravitaillement précaire une bureaucratie
et une corruption publiquement dénoncé
l'augmentation des salaires et des
primes a été depuis le début de l'année
de l'ordre d'un demi milliard de dollars
2 milliards de francs apparemment
davantage que l'on peut supporter
l'économie du pays qui dépensera rang
80,25 milliards de francs pour
s'approvisionner à l'étranger notamment
chez nous et devra à croître
régulièrement ces achats de matières
premières à l'occident dans les cinq ans
à venir
alors comment sortir de la quadrature du
cercle le leader polonais edward gierek
abordera naturellement le problème
demain à hambourg où il rencontrera
helmut schmidt l'allemagne fédérale
vient déjà d'accorder à la pologne un
prêt de 3 milliards de francs
de quoi garantir quelques fins de mois
mais les difficultés économiques formes
telles l'unique motif du trouble qui
habite la pologne
l'ampleur du mouvement actuel permet
d'imaginer que nous je vous disais que
ce coup de téléphone nous l'avions reçu
au début de l'après midi de varsovie
depuis lors mme ce direct et je voulais
a lancé avait décidé d'ajourner le
voyage qu'il devait faire un bout alors
quelle va être l'attitude possible du
gouvernement polonais va-t-il avoir
peut-être recours à la force en faisant
parvenir des formations spéciales du
service d'ordre sur le plan mondial
ne peut-on pas craindre que l'urss elle
même ne décide d'intervenir dans cette
pologne qui est regard de la carte son
voisin immédiat à sa frontière ouest
c'est ce que je demande à jean helfrid
écouter le ton du discours là que
monsieur dirait qu est en train de
prononcer va plutôt dans un sens
beaucoup plus rassurant oui il vient
même là à l'instant d'en appeler encore
la responsabilité en disant ce bien
qu'est notre pologne que nous avons
construit depuis des décennies
n'allons pas le laisser s'enfuir comme
cela en quelques instants
la pologne est un pays de tolérance un
pays de liberté de discussion
montrons que nous sommes assez grands
nous mêmes pour résoudre nous mêmes nos
propres problèmes
alors il y a quelque chose d'un peu
d'ailleurs pathétique mais d'assez
rassurant dans les propos actuels alors
je ne crois pas que l'on puisse dire à
partir de là maintenant qu'elle sera en
quelles seront les réactions car le
discours de monsieur guy reilles pour le
moment et est purement économique et ne
voit pas tout l'arrière fond qui existe
à l'heure actuelle en pologne
je vous remercie beaucoup monsieur
georges séguy ce club régional de la cgt
qui sera tout à l'heure l'un des invités
de jean pierre elkabbach la question pas
et déjà sur notre plateau je sais qui
est ce que vous exprimez ce soir à
antenne de la solidarité des
travailleurs de la santé avec les
travailleurs polonais gangrène je peux
dire que nous suivons avec beaucoup
d'attention et même d'intérêt les
événements de colonne
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire
notamment la tribune du dernier congrès
de la fédération syndicale mondiale
comme voire de grève
était un droit qui ne s'interdisait pas
que les travailleurs lorsqu'ils
n'avaient pas la possibilité de se faire
entendre ils y avaient recours y compris
dans les sociétés socialiste et qu'à ce
moment là il fallait bien discuter avec
eux de leurs problèmes ce qui se passe
un peu le haut niveau on dirait qu'on
prenait ce qui s'y est en effet passé à
gdansk absolument absolument et je
trouve que même en ce sens cette
situation ces éléments portent annuler
des perspectives fort intéressante en ce
qui concerne le dialogue la négociation
entre les travailleurs qui expriment des
raisons de mécontentement font des
propositions et les autorités depuis
socialistes d'arrêter de vous je vois
bien que le premier ministre polonais
selon rice premier ministre et monsieur
guirec lui-même le principal personnage
de l'état se met à la portée de la
compréhension des travailleurs en lutte
et discute les solutions recherche sur
le cancer cette attitude a que celle de
monsieur giscard estaing ac et j'ai
écrit il y a huit jours pour la faire de
licenciements de notre secrétaire du
syndicat de chez renault michel certano
à laquelle laquelle n'a pas de mort et
bien nous y reviendrons ici on les
travailleurs aussi pas polonais réclame
réclament des syndicats libres pour les
encourager et vous les comprenez aussi
je pense que c'est une manière périence
des mots très sain aussi nous l'avons
toujours dit que la manière dont les
syndicats sont conçus dans les pays
socialistes doit évoluer elle ne
correspond pas aux besoins d'expression
démocratie démocratiques et syndicales
qu'expriment les travailleurs et nous
avons souvent vie même dans les pays
socialistes le rôle des syndicats se
défendre les travailleurs et non pas de
réagir uniquement dans l'ombre des
partis pour
du parti et de l'état pour simplement
appliquer les décisions d'un euro ou
comme le dit au premier ministre
polonais se limiter à un rôle de
gestionnaire mais avec une pénurie
alimentaire avec l'inflation la baisse
du pouvoir d'achat et l'endettement
extérieur la crise sans matin également
la pologne qui socialisent depuis depuis
35 ans personne n'y échappe
écoutez il faudrait plus de temps pour
en parler il faudrait évoquer l'origine
de la pologne pays agraire retarder les
conséquences de la dernière guerre
mondiale à une certaine politique mais
on dirait les ai aussi lire notre
critique aussi les conséquences de la
crise du capitalisme dont l'économie
polonaise dépens et puis aussi comme la
vie guirec un certain nombre de fautes
d'erreurs d'insuffisance qui ont été
commises j'aimerais bien entendre nos
chefs d'états raisonnée de la façon et
faire leur autocritique publiquement
devant la télévision ou sur les les
causes du chômage des licenciements et
la baisse du pouvoir d'achat est trop
bien français mais peut-être que les
erreurs n'ont pas la même proportion
quelque chose autour est ce que vous
dites publiquement aujourd'hui que vous
mettez en garde contre toute
intervention de la force armée qu'elle
soit polonaise ou extérieurs à la
pologne
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait de menaces
de force armée extérieure à la pologne-
guirec a bien dit et son premier
ministre également que la pologne avait
suffisamment de force et de capacité de
régler elle-même de manière autonome ses
propres problèmes et je n'ai aucun souci
c'était si jamais ça se faisait tel
serait en position étant donné que je ne
me fais aucun souci je ne répondrai pas
à cette question
parmi les messages de sympathie qu ont
reçu grévistes polonais il y a entre
autres celui de la cfdt est celui du
syndicat mondial de la métallurgie
alors pour en revenir à question de
temps auquel participera dans un instant
ce georges tilly
je voudrais vous dire que il y aura
parmi les autres sujets à la suite ou
après la convention démocrate de new
york
comment s'annonce ce face à face le
match entre reggane et 4 pers c'est un
sujet trop baignères et une interview du
supérieur général des jésuites
le père rup et par pierre miquel
aussitôt après la fin de ce journal en
france des résultats du commerce
extérieur ont été mauvais en juillet 41
milliards d'exportations à peu près et
environs
27 milliards d'importations le déficit a
été de plus de 5 milliards de francs
mais précision par philippe sassier
c'est effectivement un déficit important
qui peut s'expliquer par trois
phénomènes tout d'abord nos achats
d'énergie sont représentés quelques 11
milliards de francs au mois de juillet
dernier à cause de l'augmentation des
prix du pétrole ils ont pratiquement
doublé par rapport au mois de juillet
dernier
ensuite il y à de forts achats effectués
par les industriels des biens
d'équipements de machines et de matériel
divers
et enfin il ya également de très forts
achats de biens pour les particuliers il
s'agit de biens de consommation courants
de voitures étrangères mais surtout
d'appareils électroménagers alors ces
chiffres sur le commerce extérieur nous
fournissent en fait deux indications
assez intéressante la première c'est que
les industriels investissent et
s'équipent pour cela il achète l étrange
où ce n'est pas un phénomène nouveau
c'est mama des problèmes qui se posent
depuis longtemps au commerce extérieur
de la france et c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle le gouvernement n'a jamais
voulu jusqu'à présent prendre des
mesures de relance général de l'économie
la deuxième remarque est bien c'est que
les particuliers semble-t-il consomment
beaucoup plus que ce que l'on croyait
jusqu'à présent et ceci au moment même
où semble-t-il
ils sont en train de regonfler leur est
pas mais nous sommes encore en été il
faudra attendre les prochaines
statistiques du commerce extérieur de
consommation et des pannes pour faire un
point plus précis sur la santé de
l'économie française à l'art entre la
macif qui est actionnaire à 30% de
manufrance tiendra un conseil
d'administration extraordinaire samedi à
paris réunion décisive dit on pour
l'avenir de la firme de saint-etienne
puisque la macif examinera sa propre
opposition va faire une france et
statuera sans doute sur les facilités
financières qu'elle se proposait
d'accorder entreprises en difficulté et
qu'elle a remis ensuite en question au
milieu de la semaine dernière les pays
pauvres vont devenir plus pauvres encore
car c'est eux qui subiront plus que
d'autres les conséquences au cours des
prochaines années
la crise économique la pauvreté ira
croissant telle est la conclusion
essentielle et pessimistes de la banque
mondiale dans son rapport sur le
développement dans le monde
un commentaire de bernard a une image
simple dans dix ans en 1990 20% de la
population du tiers-monde
devra mieux et 80% vivra encore plus mal
plus mal c'est à dire au delà de la
pauvreté absolue
à l'origine de cet appauvrissement des
causes qui elles viennent tout droit des
pays riches se sont l'inflation mondiale
la récession des pays industrialisés la
hausse en fin des prix du pétrole
trois évènements économique qui secoue
bien sûr les pays riches c'est à dire
nous mais qui sont un véritable désastre
pour les nations les plus pauvres
la donnée de base pour juger de la
prospérité économique d'un pays c'est le
produit national brut par habitant
le pnb pour les pays les plus pauvres ce
pnb n'augmentera pas de plus de 2% par
an pour les dix ans à venir
cela alors même qu'il est aujourd'hui au
plus bas premier touché les pays
d'afrique située au sud du sahara
les perspectives y sont dramatiques leur
croissance y serait négligeable d'ici à
1990 elle pourrait même être négatif
en asie la situation est un peu
meilleure la croissance atteindrait elle
les 2% en amérique latine enfin on
redescend dre de trois et demi pour cent
en moyenne à 2,2 pour cent alors que
faire la banque mondiale retient deux
initiatives pour renverser cette
tendance
d'abord les pays industrialisés doivent
relancer leur propre croissance
et acheter davantage aux pays pauvres
ensuite les pays exportateurs de pétrole
sont exhortés à investir une partie de
leur richesse dans les pays qui en ont
vraiment besoin à un terrain dans la
sphère des otages américains nouvelles
initiatives européennes avec remise au
président du parlement iranien un
message de monsieur de forme président
du conseil des ministres de la
communauté européenne et où ce terme
exprime l'espoir qu'une solution voir le
museau pages sera bientôt se trouver à
marseille ce matin décès d'une des
personnes blessées au cours de
l'attentât à l'explosif commis contre la
librairie en renoir et revendiquée par
un groupe d'extrême droite et cette
dépêche afp que je reçois de voir celui
qui résume le début du discours du
monsieur guirec
ils annoncent des augmentations de
salaires et une réforme de l'économie
mais ils refusent toute concession
politique aux grévistes c'est ce que
vous nous disiez il y a dix minutes vous
avez continué à écouter aux impressions
comment voyez vous mais moi je crois que
ce discours de monsieur guirec est une
forme de kit ouzou
car il y a mis toute son autorité toute
son autorité personnelle sachant très
bien qu'il est encore peut-être la seule
personne en pologne à une forme de
charisme encore bien personnelle et de
charisme peut-être un peu historique
je ne suis pas sûre il faudra attendre
les premières réactions qu'ils aient
répondu effectivement à toutes les
demandes
car comme nous le disions tout à l'heure
son discours est resté très économique
et n'a pas du tout abordé ni les
problèmes de politique ni les problèmes
sociaux très profonds
à la fin de son discours que nous qui
vient de se terminer à bout de 20
minutes est bien le monsieur guirec a
également fait une ouverture en
direction des syndicats
les syndicalistes et en particulier en
disant nous devons être plus attentifs à
donner plus de responsabilités aux
syndicats et toute la pologne
de haut en bas doit se sentir mobilisés
pour remédier au mal qu'il y est il a
même fait une tendu la main ou
cathodique expressément d'ailleurs dans
son discours
et il a terminé par un appel direct aux
habitants de gdansk et des trois villes
socrates qui dénie à gdansk en leur
disant vous savez il y a un plan qui est
en cours
quoi que vous demandiez vous savez très
bien que nous ne pouvons pas tout vous
donner alors rapidement au dessus tout
cela ou autour de tout cela il ya l'état
d'esprit vous revenez de punk quel est
l'état des ailes voiture est très très
lourde
il y à un phénomène de lassitude très
profondes qui se manifeste à l'heure
actuelle et je dirais que
dans l'opinion on dit de toute manière
on ne risque rien et on nous a tellement
donné le discours que plus ça change et
puis c'est pareil alors maintenant on va
jusqu'au bout il ya une espèce de deux
phénomènes la de résignation intérieure
mais qu'ils aient explosé en particulier
chez les femmes des travailleurs puisque
ce sont elles qui font les que dans les
magasins jean frélaut merci de nous
avoir aidés à comprendre ce que disait
monsieur guirec
un mot sur la température demain de
l'alsace région méditerranéenne
le temps sera encore médiocre quelques
pluies ou ondées orageuses surtout le
matin ailleurs temps plus frais nuageux
avec des éclaircies surtout près de
l'atlantique et près de la méditerranée
le mistral soufflera pas moment notre
édition est terminée ce soir hervé
claude vers 23h vous donnera des
dernières informations
mais dans un instant ce sera question de
temps l'émission de la rédaction
d'antenne 2 présenté par jean-pierre
elkabbach
bonsoir bonne soirée récit